Pharaonenschätze
und Wikipedia-Autoren.
Normalerweise arbeitet
jeder für sich am Computer,
aber in dieser Exkursion lernen sie,
wie man Museumsschätze dokumentiert.
Man kann halt dadurch irgendwo
seine Fotos, die man macht,
halt auch gut anderen Menschen
zur Verfügung stellen einfach –
und seinen Fotos auch noch
so einen gewissen Sinn geben,
indem man die einfach
in die Wikipedia einbringt.
Sie gehören zu den
freiwilligen Autoren in Deutschland.
Alle waren zuerst
einfach nur Leser von Artikeln.
Viele von ihnen sind durch das Foto-
grafieren zu Wikipedia-Autoren geworden.
Auch für das Ägyptische Museum in Leipzig
aktualisieren sie den Wikipedia-Eintrag:
über Nikauchnum
und seine Gemahlin,
ein ägyptischer Beamter,
der vor über 4.500 Jahren lebte.
Für den Hobby-Fotografen
ist auch die Fassade des Museums
einen Schnappschuss wert.
Rund zwei Million Lexikon-Einträge gibt
es schon in der deutschen Wikipedia
und jeden Tag werden es mehr.
Je nachdem wie die Lichtsituation ist,
bin ich zur passenden Zeit,
zur richtigen Zeit am Ort,
nehme das Foto auf, mache das dann
meistens auch etwas professioneller.
Und dann –
oft abends oder am Wochenende –
wenn ich dann Zeit dazu habe
und die Ruhe,
wird das Bild dann
am Computer nachbearbeitet
und dann entsprechend
auf Wikimedia-Commons veröffentlicht.
Eingeladen wurden sie
zu einem großen Wikipedia-Kongress.
Über 6.000 aktive Autoren
gibt es allein in Deutschland.
Wikipedia kann immer mehr,
alle Medien gehören
zum Online-Lexikon dazu:
über 46 Millionen Artikel weltweit,
dazu Grafiken, Foto- und Filmdateien,
Landkarten oder Statistiken.
Weil die Sammel-Leidenschaft
der Autoren nicht ausreicht,
arbeiten sie längst mit Archiven
in der ganzen Welt zusammen.
Wikipedianer möchten das
gesamte Wissen der Welt sammeln,
in der Wikipedia
und in ihren Schwesterprojekten,
aber es gibt ja schon
ganz viele Institutionen beispielsweise
und Museen, Kulturinstitutionen,
die bereits Wissen haben,
die bereits Wissen sammeln
und das heißt:
Was ist besser, als sich mit diesen
Institutionen zusammenzutun?
Sie erhalten professionelles Training
in Schreib- und Computerworkshops
oder Kamera-Seminaren.
Die Veranstaltung kostet 75.000 Euro
und die Wikimedia Deutschland,
der Dachverein,
findet es wichtig,
dieses Geld auszugeben.
Ziel dahinter ist, einerseits natürlich
die Wikipedia weiterhin zu verbessern,
die Artikel zu verbessern,
die Qualität weiterhin zu sichern –
aber auch, durch diese ganzen Online-
Kontakte, sich auch mal live zu erleben.
Berlin:
Hier befindet sich Wikimedia,
die deutsche Zentrale von Wikipedia.
100 Mitarbeiter leistet sich
das Unternehmen.
Ihr Auftrag: Sie sollen die Qualität
des Lexikons verbessern –
zum Beispiel Regeln aufstellen,
um Streitfälle zu schlichten,
wie beim Lexikon-Eintrag
von George W. Bush,
der angeblich über 40.000 Mal
hin- und her verändert wurde.
Dann gibt es auch Strukturen
innerhalb der Wikipedia,
so genannte Administratoren,
die dann in der Regel solche
Meinungsverschiedenheiten mitigieren,
das bedeutet,
dass sie da auch schauen,
wo kommen die
unterschiedlichen Meinungen her.
Und falls das immer noch
nicht zum Erfolg führt,
gibt es sogar noch ein
Schiedsgericht innerhalb der Wikipedia.
Und woher kommt das Geld?
Hier arbeiten sie an der
jährlichen Spendenkampagne.
8,6 Millionen Euro haben rund 400.000
Leser im vergangenen Jahr gespendet,
allein in Deutschland.
Für sie ist die wirtschaftliche
Unabhängigkeit wichtig.
Eine Enzyklopädie hat den Anspruch,
neutral, objektiv zu sein.
Zudem ist die Bewegung
dahinter gemeinnützig.
Mit Werbung,
mit einem Aspekt der Profitorientierung
wäre Wikipedia ganz anders,
man würde Wikipedia nicht vertrauen,
man würde den
Inhalten nicht vertrauen.
Die einen spenden Geld
und die anderen spenden Artikel.
Weltweit hat Wikimedia
40 Landesvertretungen,
auf allen Kontinenten.
Das Ganze wirkt
wie eine neuartige Wirtschaftsform
zwischen sharing economy
und Sozialismus.
Und hier glauben sie
an den Erfolg ihres Geschäftsmodells.